Right now, boys are growing up in a world where often the loudest messages about masculinity are coming from influences to profit from fear, dominance and division. And the really scary part? Those messages land because they speak straight to the insecurities that boys often don't know how to name. So today I'm welcoming back Dr Matt Slavin, clinical psychologist and we're asking the big question. How do we raise boys and young men with emotional strength, healthy confidence and compassion in a culture that often seems to reward the exact opposite. Hope you find it so useful and if you do please like and subscribe for more. Hi, welcome along to the aspiring psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne Trent and I am joined
如今，男孩们成长在一个充满各种声音的世界里，而其中最响亮的声音往往来自那些通过散布恐惧、宣扬支配和制造分裂来获利的势力。最可怕的是，这些信息之所以能产生影响，是因为它们直接触及了男孩们往往无法言说的内心不安。因此，今天我再次邀请了临床心理学家马特·斯莱文（Matt Slavin）博士，我们要探讨一个重大课题：在一个似乎总是奖励反面特质的文化中，我们该如何培养出具备情感力量、健康自信和同理心的男孩和年轻男性？希望这期节目对你有所帮助，如果喜欢，请点赞并订阅以获取更多内容。嗨，欢迎来到《有抱负的心理学家》播客，我是玛丽安·特伦特（Marianne Trent）博士，今天和我一起的是……
here today by Dr Matt Slavin who is a fellow qualified clinical psychologist. Welcome back Matt. Thank you so much. Lovely to be here. So we have met already for another episode where we're talking about the way that our brains kind of work and how they were geared up for living many, many, many years ago. So if people want to check that out, they absolutely can. I'll link that in the description. But today, we are talking about raising boys or working with boys or men. when there is such kind of a narrative around and available for them which might be misogynistic, can you tell us how your interest in that development? We've all got our, depends how deep you want to go on this one, because we've all got our reasons why we help others.
临床心理学家马特·斯莱文博士。欢迎回来，马特。非常感谢，很高兴能来到这里。我们之前已经录过一期节目，讨论了大脑的工作方式以及它们在很久很久以前是如何适应生存的。如果大家想听，完全可以去听，我会把链接放在描述栏里。但今天，我们要讨论的是在当今社会充斥着可能带有厌女色彩的叙事环境下，如何抚养男孩，或者如何与男孩和男性共事。你能谈谈你对这一发展方向的兴趣吗？我们每个人都有自己的理由去帮助他人，这取决于你想挖掘得有多深。
And I know that I felt very lost as a teen, as a young adult. And I don't think I was ever told these messages or signals. you just absorb them living in the UK as being a as a boy being a being a young man is that i didn't feel like i understood what was going on in my head and i didn't understand how to communicate that and i felt very scared of what was it what was within and and particularly scared about being something i didn't want to be being maybe bad to be aggressive maybe there's something wrong in some of these primal instincts we all have within us um and i my career ended up ended very early on working with young offenders and working with young men who'd been through
我知道我自己在青少年和刚成年时感到非常迷茫。我不认为有人曾告诉过我这些信息或信号，你只是在英国作为一个男孩、一个年轻男性生活时，自然而然地吸收了这些东西。我感觉自己不理解脑子里在发生什么，也不懂得如何去沟通。我对自己内心深处的东西感到非常害怕，尤其是害怕成为自己不想成为的人，害怕变得糟糕、变得具有攻击性。也许我们内心深处的一些原始本能出了问题。我的职业生涯很早就开始与年轻罪犯以及经历过……
hardships in their teenage years, particularly chronic ill health, which meant a lot of these teenage boys, worked with a lot of young men, been through the fostering system, through the other side, where they hadn't had the kind of experiences that help them understand their inner world, not be afraid of their inner world. And if you don't know those pieces, then we go back to some of our final fears and we violence becomes a great way to manage this world that aggression comes out because it's also a cover for fear and that's we know that there's something in us that can feel safe with some very black and white thinking or some very binary rhetoric they're the wrong ones we're the right ones better to feel strong than to feel weak and i think in today's modern age it's
青少年时期苦难的年轻人共事，特别是那些患有慢性疾病的年轻人。我接触过很多年轻人，他们经历过寄养系统，在另一面，他们没有获得那种能帮助他们理解内心世界、不再恐惧内心世界的经历。如果你不了解这些，我们就会回到一些根本的恐惧中，暴力就成了管理这个世界的一种绝佳方式。攻击性之所以会爆发，是因为它也是恐惧的掩饰。我们知道，内心深处有些东西可以通过非黑即白的思维或二元对立的言论获得安全感：他们是错的，我们是对的；感觉强大总比感觉弱小要好。我认为在当今现代社会……
very engaging and very easy really to fall into some of the less kind political narratives being put around to this world, particularly around what it means to be a man and what it means to be in this world. Yeah, I think there was kind of people really began looking at this in closer detail, kind of when Andrew Tate started kind of being very vocal on this, but also more recently with kind of the hit Netflix show Adolescents, which for me, actually, my husband and I didn't like it as much as everybody else because we felt like it touched on some very important points but never really seemed to conclude on them.
陷入一些不太友好的政治叙事是非常容易的，尤其是关于“做一个男人意味着什么”以及“在这个世界上意味着什么”的讨论。是的，我认为人们真正开始密切关注这一点，是在安德鲁·泰特（Andrew Tate）开始就此发表高论之后，但最近还有一部热门的Netflix剧集《青春期》（Adolescents）。对我来说，我和我丈夫并不像其他人那样喜欢它，因为我们觉得它触及了一些非常重要的点，但似乎从未真正得出结论。
Like I felt like we wanted more, and if they'd made it like an eight-part series, you might have got more of the depth that I was looking for. But this whole idea of in-cell, which is involuntary celibacy, and like you said, that narrative of us versus them. And, yeah, it's, I don't know, as a mother of two boys, one of whom's in end stages of primary school and one of them's in secondary school, it just feels, it feels like a heavy load. And you, like you, I've worked in youth prisons as well, like I can see where things have gone well for people and where things have gone, I've gone less well, often through no fault of their own, you know, thinking about complex trauma and all of that. stuff, but there are always still choices you can make. And I do understand that peer pressure
我感觉我们想要更多，如果他们把它拍成八集系列剧，或许能达到我所期待的深度。但关于“非自愿独身者”（incel）的整个概念，以及你所说的“我们对他们”的叙事，确实……我不知道，作为一个有两个儿子的母亲，一个正处于小学高年级，另一个在读中学，这感觉像是一个沉重的负担。像你一样，我也曾在青少年监狱工作过，我能看到人们在哪些方面做得好，在哪些方面做得不好，这往往不是他们自己的错，考虑到复杂创伤等等。但你仍然可以做出选择。我确实理解同伴压力……
can be very difficult to, you know, to guard against, and that often people will try and entice you in to their club. And if you then feel valued and respected, it can be, it's almost like leaving prison, isn't it? Like, it's hard to go and do something different when all the people that you already know are doing all of these things. It's hard to be independent and by yourself. So I do definitely have empathy and a lot of thought for what it's like to grow up as a male and a young man, but also I have fear as a woman, but also as a mother to boys. And there's some natural things here that are very helpful for us to understand. I think perhaps being a psychologist or understanding systems, understanding development that helps you understand some of it.
是非常难以抵御的，而且人们经常会试图引诱你加入他们的圈子。如果你因此感到被重视和尊重，那几乎就像离开监狱一样，不是吗？当你认识的所有人都在做这些事情时，很难去尝试做些不同的事情。很难保持独立和自我。所以我对作为一个男性和年轻男性成长的感受确实有同理心，也有很多思考。但作为一名女性，同时也是男孩的母亲，我也有恐惧。这里有一些自然的东西，理解它们对我们非常有帮助。我想，作为一名心理学家，或者理解系统、理解发展，有助于你理解其中的一部分。
It doesn't mean you can always avoid it, but there are things like when we have a primal need to belong. And so places of belonging become extremely attractive. And there are definitely there as that I remember learning in my master's, my child and adolescent psychology masters, I remember learning about the key psychosocial tasks of adolescence. There are things you need to do at some point in this life. You don't get it done in your teens. You'll do it later in your 20s, but you need to do them, which is finding group membership, you know, exploring identity, which is leaving your parents and finding a peer group who are more important socially to you than your parents, finding partners, all those extra things, exploring sexual identity. Well, that's part of it. So knowing that, it's like,
这并不意味着你总能避免它，但有些事情，比如我们有归属的原始需求，所以归属地变得极具吸引力。我记得在我的硕士课程——儿童与青少年心理学硕士——中，我学到了青少年时期的关键心理社会任务。这是你一生中必须完成的事情。如果你在十几岁时没完成，二十几岁时也会做，但你必须完成它们，比如寻找群体归属感，探索身份认同——也就是离开父母，寻找一个在社交上比父母更重要的同伴群体，寻找伴侣，以及所有那些额外的事情，探索性身份。嗯，这也是其中的一部分。所以知道这一点，就像是……
well, this is all part of what men are meant to do, is to go and find these groups and find a tribe. But I suppose one of the things I'm very mindful of, I've got a young, young boy, he's three years old, and he has big, big feelings, my little one, big feelings, because he's three years old. And he's very loud. The loudest member of our family. It always will be. He feels things strongly, and he has a short fuse. He's three years old. But that's also part of his personality. You can see how kids are shaped very early on. That I think, one of the great gifts you can try and give your children that we're trying very hard. I'm not sure we'll do it, but we're trying very hard, is to provide those two ingredients which might
好吧，这就是男人注定要做的事情，去寻找这些群体，寻找部落。但我认为我非常在意的一点是，我有一个很小的男孩，他三岁，他有非常强烈的情感，我的小家伙，情感非常强烈，因为他才三岁。而且他声音很大，是我们家声音最大的一员。他总是这样。他感受强烈，而且脾气急躁。他才三岁。但这也是他个性的一部分。你可以看到孩子们在很小的时候是如何被塑造的。我认为，你可以尝试给孩子的一份伟大的礼物——我们正在非常努力地尝试，我不确定我们是否能做到，但我们正在努力——是提供那两种可能……
help with this later in life, which is one, the skills of emotion regulation. So teaching kids how to feel and what's actually going on. So feel and deal, to feel it and to deal with it, and to feel loved just for who they are, that one may, we hope, may protect about going with groups where they feel lost and isolated so they'll take them away and that will be their tribe and that too there's always and we hope this is the case which are very very best as parents this is what I do in my parent work with other with parenting for adoptive families is that we try and help them provide a home environment where the adults are the safe figures parents are safe figures so that secure base safe haven you know somewhere to go out from but ultimately you're
有助于他们日后生活的要素，一是情绪调节的技能。教孩子们如何去感受，以及到底发生了什么。所以是“感受并处理”，去感受它并处理它，并因为他们本来的样子而感到被爱。这或许能保护他们不去加入那些让他们感到迷失和孤立的群体，从而把他们带走，成为他们的部落。第二点，我们总是希望——作为父母，我们尽了最大努力，这也是我在与收养家庭进行育儿工作时所做的——我们尝试帮助他们提供一个家庭环境，让成年人成为安全的人物，父母是安全的人物，也就是那个“安全基地”和“避风港”。你知道，那是他们出发的地方，但归根结底……
going to make mistakes as a kid. You're going to make mistakes as a teenager as a young adult. And don't we want parents who say, don't we want kids who think parents are the people to go back to and talk about it with? That's what I want for my boy. We absolutely do. And it's reminding me of a really lovely book that I listened to by Gable Mate called Hold On to Your Kids. And it's exactly what you're saying actually. And it's very interesting chapters even on kind of sexualization and sexual contact. And actually, people are more likely to becoming engaged in sexual contact if they feel like they haven't, they don't feel like they've got value elsewhere. And it's very, very interesting. So anyone listening to this or watching this,
你作为一个孩子会犯错。作为一个青少年、一个年轻成年人，你也会犯错。难道我们不希望父母说，难道我们不希望孩子们认为父母是他们可以回去倾诉的人吗？这就是我为我的儿子所希望的。我们绝对希望这样。这让我想起了一本非常棒的书，我听过盖博·马特（Gabor Maté）写的《握住你的孩子》（Hold On to Your Kids）。这正是你所说的。书中甚至有关于性化和性接触的非常有趣的章节。实际上，如果人们觉得自己在其他地方没有价值，他们更有可能参与性接触。这非常、非常有趣。所以任何听到或看到这一点的人……
if you like this conversation, I think you'll probably also like that book. But for me as a parent, it really reinforced that I want to be able to do my job well and have my children individuate themselves from me in the way that I've individuated myself from my family, but that I would, would love for them to still choose to have me in their life, not because they need me in their life, you know, that they're not still, you know, they can't be functional, they can't get things done, but they would choose to say, actually, I'd love to meet my mum for a coffee. She doesn't drink coffee, am I kidding, like a herbal tea. Or that I would really love to go out for dinner with her and my girlfriend, you know, and maybe dad will come too. Like, you know what I mean?
如果你喜欢这个对话，我想你可能也会喜欢那本书。但对我作为一名家长来说，它确实强化了这一点：我想做好我的工作，让我的孩子们以我从家庭中独立出来的方式，从我这里独立出来。但我非常希望他们仍然选择让我在他们的生活中，不是因为他们需要我，你知道，不是因为他们无法独立运作，无法完成事情，而是他们会选择说：“其实，我很想和妈妈喝杯咖啡。”（她不喝咖啡，我在开玩笑，是草本茶。）或者“我真的很想和她以及我的女朋友出去吃晚饭，也许爸爸也会来。”你知道我的意思吗？
that they will want to have me in their life and that's when i feel like i'll have done a good job what are your thoughts around that wouldn't that be lovely wouldn't that be lovely i i my wife and i often my wife's a pediatric o t sensory integration o t so she often thinks about we think too much sometimes about our kids that's that's also not so helpful by no means are we great parents we try to be good parents um we think a lot of about this and we wish for our children that they want to be with us as the girl we're at that lovely gift of life where my son is three my my daughter's five where we we are their worlds and they want to be with us we're very aware that won't last and actually we don't want it to last
他们会想要我在他们的生活中，那时我觉得我就完成了一项出色的工作。你对此有什么看法？那不是很美好吗？那不是很美好吗？我和我妻子经常……我妻子是一名儿科职业治疗师，专门研究感觉统合，所以她经常思考……我们有时对孩子想得太多了，那其实也没什么帮助。我们绝不是完美的父母，我们努力做好的父母。我们对此思考很多，我们希望我们的孩子想要和我们在一起。我们正处于人生中那个美好的阶段，我的儿子三岁，女儿五岁，我们是他们的全世界，他们想和我们在一起。我们非常清楚这不会持续……
forever we'll have to find a poem maybe i'll link it with you but there's a poem that's on on children or on parenting which the essence of a part of it is that your children are not you you don't own your children and that one of the greatest things you can do is to give all the skills for your kids to feel confidently to go out into the world by themselves and to have their own lives and they didn't ask to come into this world. So we want very much for our kids to have a great life on their own terms. But we're very mindful. There are things we could be doing now, things parents can do now about being safe containers, about being good enough. I love that book on The Power of Showing Up by Dan Gilbert and Tina Payne Bryson on
永远。我们得找一首诗，也许我会分享给你，但有一首关于孩子或育儿的诗，其核心部分是：你的孩子不是你，你不拥有你的孩子。你能做的最伟大的事情之一，就是赋予你的孩子所有技能，让他们自信地独自走向世界，拥有他们自己的生活。他们并没有要求来到这个世界。所以我们非常希望我们的孩子能按照他们自己的方式过上美好的生活。但我们非常清醒。有些事情我们现在就可以做，父母现在就可以做，关于成为安全的容器，关于做到“足够好”。我喜欢丹·西格尔（Dan Siegel）和蒂娜·佩恩·布赖森（Tina Payne Bryson）写的《塑造孩子》（The Power of Showing Up）那本书，关于……
if you can give children to feel the four s's safe, seen, soothed, and secure, those things are the great protectors of mental health and criminal activity and later life, but also the great protectors of holding on to good relationships in life. We try to. We try our best. Yeah. Yeah, I totally agree. I will check that book out.
如果你能让孩子感受到四个“S”：安全（Safe）、被看见（Seen）、被安抚（Soothed）和稳固（Secure），这些东西是心理健康和预防犯罪的伟大保护伞，也是在生活中保持良好关系的伟大保护伞。我们尝试这样做。我们尽力而为。是的，我完全同意。我会去看看那本书。
I think I've read one, a couple of what by Dan Siegel, but I've not read that one, so I will definitely check that out. Like, I tried to not Google the term Andrew Tate, but I did before our meeting. And actually, I was surprised at how relatively normal the freely available, generally understood background to him is. So I don't know how much you or our audience will know about him, but he was born in the States and he moved to Luton when his parents split up. I think he was around age 11. So then he was raised in Luton. His dad was a very competitive, successful chess player, and it's been suggested that he was largely possibly personality disorder.
我想我读过一两本丹·西格尔的书，但我没读过那一本，所以我一定会去看看。就像我试图不去谷歌搜索“安德鲁·泰特”这个词，但在我们见面之前我还是搜了。实际上，我很惊讶他那广为人知的背景竟然相对正常。所以我不知道你或我们的听众对他了解多少，但他出生在美国，父母离婚后搬到了卢顿（Luton）。我想他当时大约11岁。所以他是在卢顿长大的。他父亲是一位非常有竞争力的成功国际象棋棋手，有人认为他很大程度上可能患有人格障碍。
He was certainly a little bit grandiose and narcissistic at times. But his mum was, I think it said like a care worker or something. So in terms of the level of ability or level of high performance, for me it was stacking up as actually dad is the high achiever, world chess champion, mum, mum not so much. So maybe that's where it started. But I don't know what I was expecting. That's not what I was expecting. You know, maybe it's actually the people he was around in Luton. You know, something or a series of some things have contributed towards him developing the views that he has developed.
他确实有时有点浮夸和自恋。但我认为他母亲是一名护理人员之类的。所以就能力水平或高成就水平而言，对我来说，这看起来像是父亲是高成就者，世界象棋冠军，而母亲则不然。所以也许这就是一切的开始。但我不知道我期待的是什么。那不是我所期待的。你知道，也许实际上是他在卢顿接触到的人。你知道，某件事或一系列事情促成了他形成现在的观点。
I've never watched one of his videos. Maybe I should. Yeah, like our history doesn't have to define us, but what we will learn about what we believe as psychologists is that formulation and kind of learning about how developmental experiences can be key in understanding why we have the beliefs, the way. world views and the behaviours ultimately that we do. And also the fact that he didn't just keep these viewpoints to himself, did he? Like he went out there very publicly with it and has made kind of a lot of money from from social media and kind of talking about this. What do you think, Matt? Where you come from matters. So I think understanding your lived experience is a key part of all of our lives. I think everyone should go through therapy so they can understand themselves, not than anything wrong in particular, but you have to understand yourself.
我从来没看过他的视频。也许我应该看看。是的，我们的历史不一定要定义我们，但作为心理学家，我们所学到的是，构思（formulation）以及了解发展经历如何成为理解我们为何拥有某种信念、世界观和行为的关键。还有，他并没有把这些观点留给自己，对吧？他非常公开地表达了这些观点，并通过社交媒体谈论这些话题赚了很多钱。你觉得呢，马特？你的出身很重要。所以我认为理解你的生活经历是我们所有人生命中的关键部分。我认为每个人都应该接受心理治疗，这样他们才能了解自己，并不是因为有什么特别的问题，而是你必须了解自己。
I remember being offered some posts in Luton and being said, there's a lot of social inequality in Luton, sorry, and it's a tough place to be. So there's a lot of that that happens. So maybe it's something around there. And I would say he's very attractive in many with different ways because high performance is very attractive. The clear narrative is very attractive. He's very confident. He's very muscular and like a good looking in those ways. There's many qualities which many men won't want. Boys might want to aspire to. And I think what's really tricky is to balance again, we'll come back to primal needs is the two primal things about our tribe is competition and collaboration.
我记得曾被提供在卢顿的一些职位，有人说卢顿存在很多社会不平等，抱歉，那是一个艰难的地方。所以那里发生了很多这样的事情。所以也许这与此有关。而且我会说，他在很多方面都非常有吸引力，因为高成就非常有吸引力。清晰的叙事非常有吸引力。他非常自信。他肌肉发达，在这些方面看起来很帅。有很多品质是许多男人想要的。男孩们可能想效仿。我认为真正棘手的是再次平衡——我们回到原始需求——关于我们部落的两件原始事情是竞争与合作。
Like, I want to raise a boy who is, I want to raise a boy, he goes to martial arts. Like that's absolutely key for me. I went through martial arts and I think I learned all the right lessons about how to be aggressive in a controlled way, how to be physically strong and then to not need it. And all those things about brotherhood and I think are very important. but at the same time, then also how to live in this world in collaboration, to not think about yourself as better than others, to be able to meet anybody and just have genuine compassion and respect and curiosity about their life story and where they come from. I think that takes a little
比如，我想培养一个男孩，他去练武术。这对我来说绝对是关键。我经历过武术训练，我认为我学到了所有正确的课程：如何以受控的方式展现攻击性，如何变得身体强壮，然后不再需要它。所有关于兄弟情谊的事情，我认为都非常重要。但与此同时，也要学会如何在这个世界上协作，不要认为自己比别人优越，能够与任何人见面，并对他们的生活故事和出身抱有真诚的同理心、尊重和好奇心。我认为这需要一点……
bit more internal confidence and self-esteem to do. Otherwise, we get into hierarchies. And once we get into labels, hierarchies, dogma, then it's very easy to not treat people like humans with really detailed, lived experiences and interesting stories. Labels are always shorthand and people are far more, people are far more interesting and complex than we can possibly put down to a few words. And so we want to give people the time. I want my boy to give women, men, anyone in his world, the time to really see people beyond what he immediately sees. But it's interesting when you drew out his key features. that people might find attractive or compelling because actually I think you have you have all of
更多的内在自信和自尊才能做到。否则，我们就会陷入等级制度。一旦我们陷入标签、等级制度、教条，那么就很容易不再把人当作拥有极其详细的生活经历和有趣故事的人类来对待。标签总是简写，而人远比我们能用几个词概括的要有趣和复杂得多。所以我们想给人们时间。我希望我的儿子给女性、男性，给世界上的任何人时间，去真正看到超越他第一眼所见的人。但当你勾勒出他那些人们可能觉得有吸引力或引人注目的关键特征时，这很有趣，因为实际上我认为你也有……
those features as well and yet you are living a very different life with very different values and you talk very differently about how you would want your son to be and how you'd want your daughter to experience the world. So those features alone can't be enough to predetermine that, like, something must have reinforced this belief for him? It's hard to know why. Now, actually, I think as a clinical psychologist, the one thing we don't do is that we don't make too many assumptions. We try and make inferences and hypotheses, but you've got to know someone to really understand
所有这些特征，然而你却过着截然不同的生活，有着截然不同的价值观，而且你谈论你想让儿子成为什么样的人、想让女儿如何体验这个世界的方式也截然不同。所以仅凭这些特征不足以预先决定这一点，一定有什么东西强化了他的这种信念？很难知道为什么。现在，实际上，作为一名临床心理学家，我们不做的一件事就是不做太多假设。我们尝试进行推论和假设，但你必须了解一个人才能真正理解……
the lived experience. And I don't know that for him. But I think one thing that's very compelling, perhaps where, perhaps what's driven him, but I don't know, is there is something very compelling when you are scared in this world is to put fear out into this world or when you feel not good enough is to project that into the world. We might go back to some odd psychoanalytic terms here that I remember putting a post down not that long ago, a social media post around hate and how really hate is governed, when we project hate out and we say we don't like these things about people, about immigration,
他的生活经历。我对他并不了解。但我认为有一点非常引人注目，也许是什么驱动了他——我不知道——当你在这个世界上感到恐惧时，把恐惧投射到这个世界上，或者当你感到自己不够好时，把这种感觉投射到世界上，是非常引人注目的。我们可能会回到一些奇怪的精神分析术语，我记得不久前发过一个帖子，一个关于仇恨的社交媒体帖子，以及仇恨是如何被支配的。当我们投射仇恨，当我们说我们不喜欢关于人们的这些事情，关于移民……
about the color of someone's skin, really we're looking within and we're finding qualities in ourselves that we don't like that we're fearful of. So maybe it's our own weakness or our vulnerability, our fear of poverty, our own fears. And we project that out and then we put them onto another. And then we can hate something else because it's like we can annihilate it in another rather than actually fear it in ourselves, far more vulnerable to say we fear in ourselves. So I put a post like that. And probably one of the most commented things I've ever put out into this world. And most people, I had an unbelievable out of hate put my way in that conversation. Very, very degrading messages were put towards me. I had things like about what I said, for sure, but I had three or four messages
关于某人的肤色，实际上我们是在审视内心，我们在自己身上发现了我们不喜欢、我们感到恐惧的品质。所以也许是我们自己的软弱或脆弱、我们对贫困的恐惧、我们自己的恐惧。我们把这些投射出去，然后把它们加在别人身上。然后我们就可以去恨别的东西，因为这就像我们可以在别人身上消灭它，而不是在自己身上恐惧它——承认在自己身上恐惧要脆弱得多。所以我发了那样一个帖子。这可能是我发布过的评论最多的内容之一。大多数人……在那场对话中，我遭到了难以置信的仇恨。非常、非常贬损的信息被发给我。我收到了一些关于我所说内容的评论，当然，但我收到了三四条……
about the way I looked, the way I spoke. And I thought it was so interesting that in the very post i was putting out about actually how easy it is to ignore ourselves and to displace our own fears and dislikes into others projected into others that in very the conversation of that invoked in and it was men who were commenting invoked to me that shave your neck was one of the comments i got how disgusting shave your neck yeah um i don't shave my neck so i i wear a natural beard and i think i don't know why i don't know this man personally i I don't know his history, but I think there's something in us, particularly men. Maybe if you're not secure enough from where you are, you're going to lash out and fight and attack others.
关于我的长相、我的说话方式的评论。我觉得这太有趣了，因为在我发布的那个关于忽视自我、将自己的恐惧和厌恶投射到他人身上是多么容易的帖子中，在对话中引发的——评论的都是男性——引发了对我说“刮刮你的脖子”，这是我收到的评论之一，“真恶心，刮刮你的脖子”。是的，嗯，我不刮脖子，我留着自然的胡须。我想……我不知道为什么，我不认识这个人，我不知道他的历史，但我认为我们内心深处，尤其是男人，如果你的内心不够稳固，你就会猛烈抨击、攻击他人。
And I don't think that comes from a secure man. Yeah, I think you're probably right. But like you said, we don't know him and we've never never therapeutized him. But I watched, I think it was a panorama show that was on recently about the fall of Prince. Andrew. And as part of that, they were interviewing, obviously, old footage of Virginia, who's been the co-author of the book. She's sadly not long with us. But they were talking about what they saw in this production as being raised to be untouchable and being raised to be thinking that everyone else is below you, really. And I think it's some of what you just spoke about,
我不认为这来自一个内心稳固的男人。是的，我想你可能是对的。但就像你说的，我们不了解他，我们从未对他进行过心理治疗。但我看了，我想是最近播出的关于安德鲁王子（Prince Andrew）倒台的纪录片。作为其中的一部分，他们采访了弗吉尼亚（Virginia）的旧录像，她是那本书的合著者。她很遗憾已经不在了。但他们谈论了他们在这次制作中所看到的，即被培养成“不可触碰”的人，被培养成认为其他人都在你之下。我认为这正是你刚才所说的……
really is that we're raising people to believe that they can take whatever they want, they can do whatever they want. I tried to get hold of a copy of that book, but it was sold out. So I am definitely intending to read it for my own knowledge. But yeah, I think now we're more mindful and more switched on and more able to hold people to account. We see this in the media, don't we, is that actually the BBC won't touch anyone that's not robust anymore and not kind of bulletproof and even people that have been sacked, you know, Gary Linneka for having an opinion and, you know, rightly so on a number of topics like he was told, no, that's not okay. But we're more moving towards people having to be accountable for their actions.
实际上，我们正在培养人们相信他们可以拿走任何他们想要的，他们可以做任何他们想做的。我试着弄到那本书的副本，但卖光了。所以我绝对打算为了自己的知识去读它。但是的，我认为现在我们更加清醒、更加警觉，也更有能力让人们承担责任。我们在媒体上看到了这一点，不是吗？实际上，BBC不再接触任何不稳固、不“防弹”的人了，甚至那些被解雇的人，你知道，加里·莱因克尔（Gary Lineker）因为发表观点而被解雇，你知道，在许多话题上他是对的，就像他被告知“不，那是不行的”。但我们正更多地转向人们必须为自己的行为负责。
And that's catching people out, you know, when that's not the way that they started their career or started their life. But again, it's just really interesting food for thought for me as a mother of boys. Like, have you got any kind of, how have you watched that unfold? It's scary as well, as the other part of it, that it's scary that you need to be, well, you need to be mindful of what you put out to the world. And I think what's scary is that when I remember being a teenage boy and I remember at university, I think we all made mistakes or did silly things. But not many things of that was recorded or my opinions. I didn't tweet at the time about things as you're discovering yourself. So I think it's important to remember
这让人们措手不及，你知道，当这不是他们职业生涯或生活开始的方式时。但同样，这对我作为一个男孩的母亲来说，确实是发人深省的。你有没有……你是如何观察到这一切发展的？这也很可怕，可怕的是你需要……嗯，你需要注意你向世界发布的内容。我认为可怕的是，当我记得作为一个十几岁的男孩时，我记得在大学里，我想我们都犯过错或做过傻事。但其中很少有被记录下来的，或者我的观点。我在发现自我的过程中并没有在推特上谈论这些事情。所以我认为记住这一点很重要……
like being a teenager, being a young adult, you're trying things on for size, trying in political views, you're trying on your world view. I remember someone talking about it to me like you're trying on many different outfits, trying all those different outfits and eventually find the one that feels the most comfortable. Hopefully when you try all the outfits on, you're not hurting people in the process, you're just trying on for yourself. But I know that the data says that many men are young boys, they are being very scared and mindful about what they do in this world. So there's far less drinking culture than there was. There's far less sexual activity because of the fears of it. And I think part of that is in the right direction of helping people understand
作为一个青少年，作为一个年轻成年人，你在尝试不同的尺寸，尝试政治观点，尝试你的世界观。我记得有人跟我谈论过，就像你在试穿许多不同的衣服，试穿所有那些不同的衣服，最终找到那件感觉最舒服的。希望当你试穿所有衣服时，你没有在这个过程中伤害别人，你只是在为自己尝试。但我知道数据表明，许多年轻男孩感到非常害怕，并注意他们在世界上所做的事情。所以饮酒文化比以前少多了。由于恐惧，性活动也少多了。我认为其中一部分是朝着帮助人们理解……
their actions have consequences. But we also know our teenage developing brains, the last piece of the puzzle to really develop is the part of our brain that can really think about inhibition control and to think through the consequences of our actions. So I think when I think about raising my boy and raising teenagers, I think there are some core aspects here that we all need. I think men need a way to channel their aggression. I think there's ways that boys and men all need to have ways to challenge one another. I think there's an area here where they need to play with the idea of dominance and submission and play with the idea of aspiring, and achieving in life all those things which are kind of primal drivers but healthy ways to do it so i think
他们的行为有后果的正确方向。但我们也知道我们青少年发育中的大脑，最后一块真正发育的拼图是能够真正思考抑制控制、思考行为后果的那部分大脑。所以我认为当我想到抚养我的儿子和抚养青少年时，我认为这里有一些我们需要的所有核心方面。我认为男人需要一种渠道来引导他们的攻击性。我认为男孩和男人都需要有挑战彼此的方式。我认为这里有一个领域，他们需要玩弄支配和服从的概念，玩弄抱负和在生活中取得成就的概念，所有这些都是原始驱动力，但需要以健康的方式进行。所以我认为……
sport becomes a wonderful way sport where there's a group mentality sport where your men are going to hold you to account so there's certain i always think um i've always been a big proponent of martial arts because i think in those communities and most of those communities you have people who you you just can't have too big an ego and they'll drop you down and you have to be honest and you have to be honest with yourself and your limitations. And there's a vehicle there to get out aggression and to play with challenge and to play with what it means to assert yourself and to feel that you're not as powerful as you perhaps think you are. You know, once you're in an echo chamber and you only hear your own voices as if your voice is the most important thing in the world. That's not the
运动成为了一种绝佳的方式，一种有群体心态的运动，一种你的同伴会让你承担责任的运动。所以我总是认为……我一直是一个武术的大力支持者，因为我认为在那些社区中，大多数社区里，你不能有太大的自我，他们会让你冷静下来，你必须诚实，你必须对自己和自己的局限性诚实。那里有一个释放攻击性的载体，可以玩弄挑战，玩弄“坚持自我”意味着什么，并感觉到你并不像你想象的那么强大。你知道，一旦你进入了一个回声室，你只听到自己的声音，就好像你的声音是世界上最重要的东西。事实并非如此。
case. I don't have all the answers. I wish I did. But I think knowing what we're compelled to do, some of those drivers and finding good healthy, creative outlets are important. But I'll add this in as well. When I went to university, I didn't study politics to start with. I studied geography and I went to a place that all of geography, human geography, all of my modules were things around deconstructing narrative. So it was about feminism, geographies of power, geographies of race, geopolitics, thinking about the philosophy of thought and science, helping have the tools to deconstruct narrative and deconstruct what's going on in this world the scientific method or other ways around that
我没有所有的答案。我希望我有。但我认为了解我们被迫去做的事情，了解其中一些驱动力，并找到好的、健康的、创造性的出口是很重要的。但我还要补充一点。当我上大学时，我起初并没有学习政治。我学习的是地理，我去了一个地方，所有的地理，人文地理，我所有的模块都是关于解构叙事的内容。所以它是关于女性主义、权力的地理、种族的地理、地缘政治，思考思想和科学的哲学，帮助拥有解构叙事和解构这个世界上正在发生的事情的工具，科学方法或其他相关方式……
i think are the kind of things we should be teaching young men so that they're able to they're not just see what comes out as a truth see what comes out as something just to wear as a great label or a great identity to have the skill set to be able to challenge and make their own mind up that's maybe a skill we don't do enough of in school but i think's key part this actually. Yeah, I couldn't agree more. And even last week they were talking about adding mortgage understanding and finances into education. And I think there's definitely something more that needs to change. It isn't just financial literacy, is it? It's really difficult to be a clinician and sometimes be offended or really very much disagree with the viewpoint or
我认为这是我们应该教给年轻人的东西，这样他们就能够……他们不仅仅是看到作为真理发布的东西，看到作为仅仅是穿戴的伟大标签或伟大身份的东西，而是拥有能够挑战并做出自己决定的技能。这也许是我们学校做得不够的技能，但我认为这是其中的关键部分。是的，我完全同意。甚至上周他们还在谈论将抵押贷款理解和财务知识纳入教育。我认为绝对还有更多需要改变的地方。这不仅仅是金融素养，对吧？作为一名临床医生，有时感到被冒犯，或者非常不同意你所坐的人的观点或……
world viewpoint of the person that you're sitting with. And of course, our audience might well be finding themselves to be in a clinical situation with someone who maybe is starting to voice more kind of misogynistic narrative. I know this is a big question, but how could we begin to respond to that? With curiosity, we start there, we start by being really interested. and curious. There might be a compulsion to explain and to help them see differently, to retrain for thought, but I can only imagine what we know about the way our brains work is that's going to make somebody be more defensive. Maybe they won't come back. Maybe they don't want to attain this. They feel spoken to. They feel lectured at. Maybe the very reasons why they're
世界观，这真的很困难。当然，我们的听众可能发现自己正处于与某人的临床情境中，那个人可能开始表达更多厌女的叙事。我知道这是一个大问题，但我们该如何开始回应呢？带着好奇心，我们从那里开始，我们从真正感兴趣和好奇开始。可能有一种解释并帮助他们以不同方式看待事物的冲动，去重新训练思维，但我只能想象我们所知道的关于大脑工作方式的知识，那只会让某人变得更加防御。也许他们不会再回来。也许他们不想获得这个。他们感到被说教了。也许这正是他们……
looking for those narratives in the first place. I think curiosity is the great way in this. And like you say, you do this so well when you talk about work with your clients is you really go layer by layer by layer down down to the depths. And I think if people can really understand themselves better and we're allowing ourselves to be curious with them, because they may not want to be curious about themselves. I mean, I think that is part of it. Most men, I'd say this, I think a lot of men are fearful of being curious about themselves, where it might take them, that that's going to lead them to the path to be open to have the kind of conversations, they don't let their brain do so often where they come from what was like growing up in their
最初寻找这些叙事的原因。我认为好奇心是进入这里的绝佳方式。就像你说的，当你谈论与客户的工作时，你做得非常好，你真的层层深入到深处。我认为如果人们能更好地理解自己，我们允许自己对他们保持好奇，因为他们可能不想对自己感到好奇。我的意思是，我认为这是其中的一部分。大多数男人，我会这么说，我认为很多男人害怕对自己感到好奇，害怕这会把他们带向何方，害怕这会引导他们走向开放的道路，去进行那些他们不常让大脑进行的对话，关于他们来自哪里，在家庭中成长是什么样的，他们学到的课程，因为这些都是我们在生活中学习到的课程。有些CBT（认知行为疗法）在像为事物提供简写方面很有帮助，比如你知道，生活的假设和我们的核心信念，帮助人们理解这是被教给我们的，我们在生活中学习到了这一点，这不仅仅是……
family home the kind of lessons they learned because these are all lessons we learned some of CBT is helpful in like having shorthand for things like you know assumptions for living and our core beliefs helping people understand this was taught to us we learned this in life it's not just it's not just what we've got it's we've learned this somewhere So I think being curious with somebody, saying that you want to be with them, even people you disagree with, I think especially important to be with people you disagree with. And to be open to be curious what it means for you as well. None of us are right. None of us are all right. I would say that's where you've got to be, including when you find it offensive, including when you find it personally attacking, that maybe one of the great skills is to be able to be able to be. to not accept or to say I agree with you, but to stay with them long enough to find out where it comes from. If we think about behaviour change, deep rooted identity change, I would argue that's probably the only way you're going to make significant change. And you're so
我们所拥有的，这是我们在某处学习到的。所以我认为对某人保持好奇，说你想和他们在一起，即使是那些你不同意的人，我认为与你不同意的人在一起尤为重要。并且要开放，对这对你意味着什么也保持好奇。我们没有人是正确的。没有人是完全正确的。我会说这就是你必须处于的位置，包括当你觉得它令人反感时，包括当你觉得它是在人身攻击时，也许伟大的技能之一就是能够……不接受或说我同意你，但要和他们待得足够久，找出它来自哪里。如果我们考虑行为改变、根深蒂固的身份改变，我会说这可能是你唯一能做出重大改变的方式。而且你如此……
nicely remind us actually that if someone is telling us what they think, this is a really privileged position to be in and it's a chance to hear them. but also it brings me back to kind of some of the systemic literature about potentially thinking about this as a single session intervention. If this is the only time I'm going to see this person, how can I impart the best possible, you know, intervention here? So rather than thinking, oh, I could do this in 10 sessions, they might disengage, they might never come back.
好心地提醒我们，实际上如果有人在告诉我们他们的想法，这是一个非常特权的地位，这是一个倾听他们的机会。但这也让我想起了一些关于系统性文献的内容，即潜在地将此视为单次干预。如果这是我唯一一次见到这个人的机会，我如何在这里传达最好的、可能的干预措施？所以与其想，哦，我可以在10次会话中做到这一点，他们可能会脱离，他们可能永远不会回来。
So it's giving us up a mission to be as effective, as powerful, to potentially be the different that makes the difference as soon as you can because you might only get one chance. And also with funding restrictions in kind of different mental health provisions as well, the other you're going to get like three or four sessions, that's going to be it. So we're going to need to really think about doing our best stuff. Yeah, not an easy topic that we've grappled with, but I think we've done all right. Is there anything before we finish that you think we've missed out on that we should kind of finish with Matt?
所以这给了我们一个使命，要尽可能有效、有力，尽可能成为那个带来改变的“不同”，因为你可能只有一次机会。而且随着不同心理健康供给中的资金限制，你可能只会得到三四次会话，仅此而已。所以我们需要真正考虑尽我们所能。是的，这不是一个我们处理过的简单话题，但我认为我们做得还不错。在我们结束之前，你认为我们有什么遗漏的、我们应该以什么结束吗，马特？
Maybe what I'll say as well is in the data we've got and my personal clinical experience that engaging hard-to-reach men, maybe the men who won't come to therapy, because we only know about 36% of referrals in the NHS for psychological therapies are men, that we need to speak the language that's going to attract them. So that's important. And also go to places that will attract them. And so working out in nature, thinking about creative ideas for groups or therapy is really important. to even get to see the kind of people who we're trying to reach. And so that's why I spend so much time outdoors with men, fathers and sons and adults. So speak the language and find the right place where people will be welcome and feel welcome. Wonderful. Dr. Matt Slavin, where can people learn more about you and your work? You can go to my website, Dr. Matt Slavin, s-l-A-V-I-N-com, and find out all about me. I will do a weekly newsletter. You can sign up and hear my words each week. I'm on LinkedIn under the same name, Dr. Matt Slaven,
也许我还要说的是，在我们拥有的数据和我的个人临床经验中，吸引难以接触的男性，也许是那些不会来接受治疗的男性——因为我们只知道NHS（英国国家医疗服务体系）中约36%的心理治疗转诊是男性——我们需要说出能吸引他们的语言。这很重要。而且还要去那些能吸引他们的地方。所以在大自然中工作，思考小组或治疗的创造性想法非常重要，甚至能见到我们试图接触的那类人。这就是为什么我花这么多时间和男人、父亲和儿子以及成年人在户外活动。所以说他们的语言，找到人们会受到欢迎并感到受欢迎的正确地方。太棒了。马特·斯莱文博士，人们可以在哪里了解更多关于你和你工作的信息？你可以去我的网站，Dr. Matt Slavin，s-l-a-v-i-n点com，了解关于我的一切。我每周会发一份时事通讯。你可以注册并每周听到我的话。我在LinkedIn上用同样的名字，Dr. Matt Slaven，
or you can find me on Instagram, mental.advantage. Amazing. I'm definitely going to join your mailing list because I have so enjoyed both of these conversations. Wishing you well, if I can help with anything in future, do let me know. But thank you so much again for your time. Thank you. Thank you so much. Well, how lucky am I that Dr. Matt commented on my Instagram and I followed him back and we got chatting because I think,
或者你可以在Instagram上找到我，mental.advantage。太棒了。我一定会加入你的邮件列表，因为我非常享受这两次对话。祝你一切顺利，如果未来我能帮上什么忙，一定要告诉我。但再次非常感谢你的时间。谢谢。非常感谢。好吧，我有多幸运，马特博士评论了我的Instagram，我回关了他，我们聊了起来，因为我认为……
that was a fascinating listen watch. I love being part of it. I hope that you loved receiving it as well. So yeah, I love your thoughts. What's this resonated for you? Do let me know in the comments if you're watching on YouTube or if you're listening on Spotify, you can drop a comment as well. If you're listening on Apple Podcasts, you can rate and review the show. You can give me your feedback about episodes in that way as well. come and follow me on socials where I am Dr. Marianne Trent everywhere. If you would like a chance to support me in a kind of Patreon sort of way, but that I give you something back as a bit of a thank you, then why not consider becoming a paid subscriber to my YouTube or my Spotify
这是一次引人入胜的收听和观看体验。我很高兴能参与其中，也希望你同样喜欢。所以，我很想听听你的想法。哪些内容引起了你的共鸣？如果你是在YouTube上观看，请在评论区告诉我；如果你是在Spotify上收听，也可以留下评论。如果你是在Apple Podcasts上收听，可以为节目评分和撰写评论，这也是向我反馈剧集的好方法。欢迎在社交媒体上关注我，我的账号在各平台都是Dr. Marianne Trent。如果你想以类似Patreon的方式支持我，同时又能获得我的一点回馈作为感谢，不妨考虑成为我YouTube或Spotify的付费订阅者。
or my Apple Podcasts, which you can do by checking out all the details in the show notes or by clicking any of the links in my social media. It's your way of saying thank you for this content because it does cost me many, many hundreds of pounds to produce per month. So yeah, when you vote with a couple of pounds from your pocket each month, that helps support my costs as a creator, but helps me to know that you really value this content. The podcast will always be free. You know, I would never consider putting that behind a paywall. So yeah, that another way to have a sneak peek behind the camera. The episodes that I film exclusively do not come from this seat. They are in other areas of my house and you kind of get to be
或者订阅我的Apple Podcasts，你可以查看节目说明中的详细信息，或点击我社交媒体上的任何链接来完成。这是你对这些内容表示感谢的方式，因为我每月制作节目的成本高达数百英镑。所以，当你每月从口袋里拿出几英镑来支持我时，这不仅能帮助我分担作为创作者的成本，也能让我知道你真的很重视这些内容。播客将永远免费，我绝不会考虑将其设为付费墙内容。所以，这也是另一种让你一窥镜头背后的方式。我专门拍摄的剧集并非出自这个座位，而是在我家里的其他区域，你可以更近距离地观察，
a bit more fly on the wall and kind of, yeah, to have a think about what goes into planning these episodes and I can evolve as time goes on as well. So let me know what you think to it. Let me know what you would like to know. Let me know what you would like to see. And I will certainly consider that too. If you don't already subscribe to me on YouTube, why not? Please do take some time to click that subscribe, maybe even click Notify as well. We recently reached 2,500 subscribers on the channel and honestly I was thrilled. You know, I've grown, I think it was 26th of June that I had 2,000 subscribers and now I'm recording this in November and it's the first weekend I think in November that I reached
像墙上的苍蝇一样，去思考这些剧集是如何策划的，以及随着时间的推移我如何不断进步。所以，请告诉我你的想法，告诉我你想了解什么，想看什么，我一定会认真考虑。如果你还没有订阅我的YouTube频道，为什么不呢？请花点时间点击订阅，甚至可以点击通知。我们最近在频道上达到了2500名订阅者，老实说我非常激动。你知道，我记得6月26日时我有2000名订阅者，现在我是在11月录制这段内容，我想这是11月的第一个周末，我达到了
2,500. So yeah, thank you so much if you're already a subscriber. If you're not subscriber, please do take a moment to just click on that little subscribe button if you are watching on YouTube. Thank you again for being part of my world and please let me know any content that you would find helpful and I will do my best to consider how I can bring that to being. to become a psychologist then let this be your guide with this podcast at your side you'll be on your way to being qualified
2500名。所以，如果你已经是订阅者，非常感谢你。如果你还不是，请花点时间点击那个小小的订阅按钮，如果你是在YouTube上观看的话。再次感谢你成为我世界的一部分，请告诉我任何你觉得有帮助的内容，我会尽力考虑如何将其实现。如果你想成为一名心理学家，那就让这个播客成为你的指南，有它在身边，你离获得资格就不远了。
it's the aspiring psychologist podcast with Dr. Maria and Trent Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是由Dr. Marianne Trent主持的《有抱负的心理学家》播客。谢谢。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。